hör auf sich da jemand freut die Sonne
scheint Tim Bendzko kommt vorbei
wir backen heute wir spielen heute das
wird schön
er kann wahrscheinlich den Wortwitz
nicht mehr hören ne wann kommst du
endlich die Welt retten aber jetzt kann
das nicht mehr drücken egal was das Ding
geschrieben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so da bin ich
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es endlich mal wieder eine
neue Folge zu Gast bei Sally ich freue
mich schon seit Wochen auf meinen
heutigen Gast er ist ein wahnsinnig
toller Künstler einer der besten Musiker
die wir hier in Deutschland haben
Alltag nicht er sieht einfach immer
gleich aus er ist wahnsinnig herzlich
sehr gut aussehend und hier ist er Tim
Bendzko und hat ein Hängebauch
ich freue mich sehr ich freue mich auch
dass ich hier sein darf
aus Berlin hierher das habe ich noch
vergessen
ja sehr gut bei euch schlafen können
aber ich liebe meinen Kindern
aber
Badezimmer und so weiter durftest ja
sehr gutes kaltes Wasser
und ihr habt eine sehr gute er hat eine
sehr gute kühle in eurem kalten Wasser
also nicht kalt ist oh Gott wie kann das
ist wow ich muss sogar im Sommer warm
duschen
also von der Woche konnte ich das auch
noch nicht
deswegen bleibt
ich freue mich dass du da bist das ganze
Team freut sich
und wir haben heute spannendes vor wir
wollen zusammen was kochen backen würde
jetzt mal sagen ist eigentlich kein
Backen ob es ein Auspacken in der Pfanne
das Team hat Spiele vorbereitet freue
ich mich sehr darauf
denn mein Thema verrückt
die sind bisschen
mehr
wer weiß was du vorbereitet haben ich
sehe da vorne nur so eine riesen Box und
ich durfte gestern das Studio nicht
betreten sie haben mich ausgesperrt und
saßen hier bis Mitternacht fast ich lass
mich überraschen überraschen und du hast
mir schon verraten dass du
Kaiserschmarrn liebst so kann man das
Zusammenpassen eigentlich blöd das war
jetzt zusammen zubereiten weil wenn er
ein leidenschaftlicher Kaiser schon
besser ist dann ist für mich jetzt
eigentlich so warum tue ich mir das an
aber okay wir machen jetzt einfach
klasse süß mit so Rosinen oder willst du
so eine richtig freaky Kombination wir
können auch an den backschrank jederzeit
können auch Zutaten reinschmeißen eher
so klassisch
[Gelächter]
reingucken was dir gefällt hier sprechen
ja
aber so werden wir schon wieder zu fancy
ja kommen wir später damit Runden war
hier diese Grundzutaten ab ich habe drei
Wochen nichts gegessen damit ich jetzt
hier Kaiserschmarrn richtig
ja vielleicht noch machen können ähm das
war den Kaiserschmarrn abwandeln und
noch was herzhaftes machen
ja okay aber wir starten ne
denn im türkischen heißt auch sprich süß
nein warte warte noch mal der dem
türkischen heißt auch ist süß und sprich
süß
genau
in meiner App und ähm ich würde sagen
wir starten auch direkt wie Kochen back
erfahren bist du sehr
also ich ja also ich koche schon viel
muss ich sagen aber jetzt selten so
fansachen
Kaiserschmarrn habe ich schon das ein
oder andere Mal gemacht aber immer das
ist da wurde ich immer angeleitet ich
habe den noch nie alleine zu Hause
gemacht ja aber wenn du mir sag was ich
tun soll
meine beiden linken Hände werden alles
geben das kriegen zum Beispiel nach
eiweißaufschlagen guck mal ja ich habe
zwar ein Handrührgeräte aber ich dachte
mir
ist auch kein Paar tauglicher ja denkt
man nämlich auch mit ne okay dann tun
wir erstmal die Eier trennen magst du
das machen
okay zwei Gefäße
Eigelb zu mir
wichtig ist es darf gar kein Eigelb
habe
jetzt keine Vorträge halten das ist das
eigentlich nicht gibt aber kann ich
nicht
währenddessen community-fragen
beantworten
oder ja ich bin gespannt deine erste
musikalische Erfahrung war und Frauen
bewusst ist ich werde Musiker oder ich
bin Musiker also das wusste ich
tatsächlich mit so zehn elf da bin ich
so bin ich so durch die nur zu Hause so
rumgelaufen und habe ganz nüchtern
überlegt was ich denn so werden könnte
ja und habe dann so überlegt was muss
das sein was mich erfüllt was ich gut
kann was mir nicht langweilig wird und
habe beschlossen nicht mehr länger und
da wusstest du das schon dass du gut
sein kannst
dran glaube kann aus mir auch noch eine
Sängerin werden das ist jetzt schwierig
ja ich glaube das ist tatsächlich ein
bisschen der Vorteil gewesen dass ich so
früh dran war da passiert also du hörst
dann Musik und dann singst du da so ein
bisschen mit und imitierst natürlich
dann irgendwie Sänger ich glaube
wirklich fest daran dass ich dann so ein
bisschen auch Stimme dadurch bildet
quasi also ich klinge heute so wie ich
mir das als Kind gewünscht habe dass ich
so klingen möchte
und das kurz vorm stimmt wahrscheinlich
noch
unserer Zeit da waren wir noch nicht so
früh pubertär wie die Kinder und Jugend
heute muss man dazu sagen
doch länger dauert also ich bin hier
gleich soweit
benutzt aber ich gebe dir gleich
hier kriegst du noch mal Salz von mir
richtig wichtig damit das Eiweiß
schneller in der Struktur zerstört wird
und wir schneller aufschlagen können
und ich muss dich mal loben also alles
Eier drin kannst du irgendwas muss ich
ja können das sieht super
ausschlagen ja wir schlagen so ein
bisschen
schneller das wieder machen so eine Art
beibringen bin großer Johann Lafer
Fans
Klassentreffen machen und dann ging es
dann los
ja ich habe dann 2009 an so einem
Wettbewerb teilgenommen hier in Mannheim
von ein paar Gewinnern war das war für
mich so innerlich so ein bisschen der
Startschuss also Wikipedia nachlesen
würde sieht so aus als wäre ich dadurch
dann zur Musik gekommen stimmt natürlich
nicht aber so innerlich habe ich so
gedacht okay das ist scheint dann doch
irgendwie das Richtige für mich zu sein
und dann habe ich meinen ich habe als
ochsenator gearbeitet
und dann habe ich 2000 und
2010 nee neun auch noch habe ich dann
meinen Job gekündigt und einfach ja dann
mal bei einer Plattenform angerufen und
gesagt Freunde ich bin jetzt soweit wir
können anfangen
schon ganz lange Management
und ich habe dann irgendwann so mit 16
habe ich unseren Comedy Programm
mitgespielt und daraus hat sich das so
ein bisschen entwickelt dass dann
irgendwann sollte dann so ein Auftritt
stattfinden der wurde abgesagt und dann
habe ich gesagt naja wenn ihr das dabei
eigentlich schon gebucht hat kann ich
doch dein Konzert spielen und habe dann
auch so einer ganz kleinen Bühne
konzertisch für eine ganz vielen Songs
die nächsten Monat vorher alle noch
nicht gab
und das war dann ein bisschen der
Startschuss oder wird er aus dem ganz
kleinen Mini Konzert oder so 20 Leute
waren von denen die meisten meine
Verwandten waren du kannst ja
tatsächlich so ganz klassisch eigentlich
angefangen mit irgendwie in Berlin die
Clubs abspielen quasi da gab es noch
keinen Internet
sprechen
29 dann bist du 32
unterschrieben dann und dann geht das so
klassisch los Album aufnehmen
deswegen hat man Plattenvertrag
tatsächlich und das ist auch eigentlich
das was man dann bei dem Plattenvertrag
verhandelt nämlich was kriegt man da an
Vorschuss
damit man das finanzieren kann
tatsächlich also von meinem ersten
Vorschuss habe ich nichts anderes
gemacht als das Album zu bezahlen
und dann kommt man dann irgendwann mit
einem fertigen Album und hoffe dass Sie
wissen abnehmen wenn sie sagen nee da
musst du halt noch mal
und es war ja zu der Zeit noch mal was
anderes wie heute ne damals hast du ein
Alkohol gebracht
hast dadurch wahrscheinlich auch dann
mit ja klar
keine Platten mehr damals tot jetzt
wissen was anfühl wenn sie wirklich tot
ist
2011 total das Thema dass man jetzt eben
das Downloaden kann
macht jetzt kein Mensch mehr jetzt wird
nur noch geschrieben
haben das auch dann wirklich legal zu
tun
Gott sei Dank nicht ganz steif schlagen
so bisschen schlotzig das gleiche aber
mehr brauchen wir schon noch wir können
aber auch den Joker ziehen und Sandro
drücken nee das ist die Blöße geben wir
uns jetzt nicht aber muss auch sagen
dass damals tatsächlich auch noch von
Singles also von einzelnen Songs also
von Welt retten also die ersten drei
vier Songs da gab es wirklich noch
physische Singles
aller erstes Single meine allererste CD
lass mich raten
ich habe auch ich habe auch alles ich
glaube auch wirklich kein Spaß ich
glaube dass mein erstes Album ein
Backstreet Boys Album ich glaube ich bin
mir nicht ganz sicher aber so wenn ich
mich so zurück erinnere da war ich dolle
mit dabei ja
[Musik]
jetzt nur Hits
nicht auf Konzerte gehen und es war ein
tiefes Loch in meinem Herzen und ich
habe dann die Poster gesammelt in seinem
Ordner kein Kinderzimmer zum Aufhängen
und dann habe ich mir als Erwachsener
irgendwann den Traum erfüllt und war auf
einem Backstreet Boys Konzert 2019
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich kann nicht mehr wie geil ja
vielleicht habe ich geweint ich bin
eigentlich kein so Fan Girl aber bei den
Backstreet Boys vielleicht kam da die
Emotionen mit mir durch die 16-jährige
Sally so ein bisschen und dann war es
einfach
das ist perfekt dieser Eischnee schaut
sich an
wir machen jetzt nicht den Kopf
wir brauchen den so so bisschen so
Schlotze das Ding ist auch so
anstrengend dass jetzt total okay ist
wenn ich nachher 3 kg
trainiert
Zucker und Tonka paste
noch ein bisschen Zitrone und abbrechen
ganz wichtig
am besten aus weil ich habe diese Tablet
auch
so da habe ich tatsächlich ein Video von
dir gesehen das ist wirklich kein Spaß
wirklich viele gefragt das ist auch eine
Frage hier auf meiner Karte von der
Community wie kamst du überhaupt also
seit wann kennst du mich also
seit 2000 und warte mal ich muss rechnen
jetzt wieder ich glaube seit 22 ich habe
jetzt hier auf morgen
eigentlich kann man die
pfannkuchenfunktion nehmen es gibt eine
pfannkuchenfunktion ich hätte die
Anleitung lesen soll
Kurzvideos von mir schauen und zwar ist
das hier der bratsensor und der
bratsensor hat fünf Stufen Stufe 5 ist
ein Fleisch anbraten Stufe 1 ist wenn
man Butter erwärmen will aber die soll
nicht spritzen ich weiß aber das Stufe 4
die Pfannkuchen ist
und die Pfanne die wird jetzt heiß und
dann macht und dann weißt du jetzt ist
die Temperatur erreichen und der Mist
quasi immer die rückwärme und stellt
sich immer wieder ein egal was du gerade
drinnen hast das macht dich völlig
fertig habe ich wirklich genau die
gleiche ja
es war 2019 oder
bin ich umgezogen musste in der Küche
planen
deshalb kam ich auf diese hier und dann
googelt man das und dann habe ich Videos
von dir gesehen hast du das so
präsentiert dass ich dachte das ist das
richtige Gerät so guck mal dann darfst
du gerne den Kaiserschmarrn weitermachen
was muss ich tun
dritte kurz einrühren bisschen Milch
einrühren
bisschen Butter einrühren und Eischnee
so in drei Portionen okay das also ja
ich mache erstmal ein bisschen was ja
immer so ein bisschen was davon
die Butter für den Geschmack
[Musik]
das ist sobald man das unter Anleitung
tut hat man vor jedem einzelnen Schritt
richtig Panik zu Hause würde man das da
einfach reinschmeißen
dann wundern bei uns nichts wird
das ist halt nicht klumpt also wenn ich
jetzt zu viel Milch reingehe und dann
das Mehl kriegst du einfach nur Teig
Klumpen deswegen machen wir so ein
bisschen den Wechsel und Eischnee damit
nichts zerfällt ganz am Ende verstehe
ich und der wird aber so richtig runter
gehoben ne der wird nicht runtergerührt
ne Katze
[Musik]
damit das Mehl später nicht so klebrig
wird und jetzt nehmen wir den Eischnee
gebe ich das auch da mache ich das auch
damit oder
so
leicht
nach oben
bist du generell eher so der salzige
oder der süße Typ
also wahrscheinlich bin ich schon eher
doll der süße Typ aber halte mich damit
sehr stark zurück also es hat sich meine
wahrscheinlich meine erste Süßspeise die
ich dieses Jahr zu mir nehme
bin im Training wann startet deine Tür
am ersten April
und noch ein Album kommt ja immer
freitags raus wer jetzt natürlich noch
besser gewesen wenn der erste auf jeden
Fall gewesen wäre
aber das kommt das Album am 31 und die
Tour starte zumindest am ersten April in
Köln bist natürlich eingeladen wenn Du
da in Köln
da versuche ich richtig das wird glaube
ich wirklich ziemlich lustig werden
immer rein gerne
einfach die Pfanne ist nicht die Größte
was rein oh
lucky
lassen das schön ausbacken von der einen
und dann von der anderen Seite da bin
ich sehr gespannt wie das gleich von dir
gedreht wird
machen wir mal so und ich würde jetzt
aber doch von der Stufe 1 runtergehen
weil es jetzt kein dünner Pfannkuchen
sondern so ein dicker Kaiserschmarrn
dass der nicht unten damit er auch ein
bisschen von innen auch was kriegt
verstehe cool dann komme ich mit mit zur
Tour da freue ich mich
auch sagen
aber Du musst keine Angst haben ich hole
niemand auf die Bühne ich hatte das
einmal war ich bei dem Konzert
für einmal bei einem Konzert von einem
Freund von mir der dann auch anfing
nein aber der wollte mich dann auch auf
die Bühne plötzlich holen ich finde
sowas so unangenehm wenn man irgendwo
ist und da jetzt wirklich ein Zuschauer
sein will und dann da hochgeholt wird
das würde ich nie machen passiert
und dann habe ich gesagt
ich mag deine Filme und er sagt you made
my night und dann waren wir vorbei und
dann war ich
okay
dein neues Album heißt April ja warum
geht es unter dem Album wie würdest du
das Album beschreiben
aber also ich kam so ein bisschen drauf
weil die Songs natürlich sich ein
bisschen mit den Emotionen die ich so
die letzten drei Jahre hatte beschäftigt
und dass er immer so ein Auf und Ab war
so wie der april also ist ne das wird
immer mal besser mal wieder schlechter
und denkst immer jetzt ist bald gut das
schöne ist am Ende irgendwann ist dann
also wir sind sicher irgendwann ist
wirklich gut du weißt noch nicht genau
wann bei mir die
Welt immer
[Musik]
mach was ich will mach was ich will
es sind chaotische Zeiten noch ist gar
nicht mehr weit sein und werde mich wie
Phönix aus der Asche neuen Feier im
April wie im April und das ist so ein
bisschen also die Songs die Reihenfolge
der Songs auf dem Album ist auch so dass
das so zwei Wellen sind so von das ist
gut es wird ein bisschen komisch es wird
sehr komisch es wird wieder gut wieder
komisch wieder gut ich bin auch in April
genau
die ganze Zeit so hinter der Kamera denn
ich glaube sie starten gleich mit dem
Spiel
eine Zuschauer Bianca fragt nämlich und
das frage ich mich auch wie war deine
Arbeit mit Sebastian das war ganz
angenehm tatsächlich
also ich habe vorher gesagt ich mache
das nur wenn es wirklich eine
Zusammenarbeit ist und nicht einfach so
ein hier schreibt mal irgendeinen Song
so und dann das war ja auch zu Corona
Zeiten ich habe es noch nicht gelesen
muss ich zugeben obwohl ich schon viele
Bücher von ihm gelesen habe aber
Playlist war es ne Playlist habe ich
noch nicht gelesen es liegt auf meinem
Nachttisch ich muss noch ich habe es
gelesen ist aber es war tatsächlich
wirklich ganz Fußball
genau besprochen haben wie was wo
passiert da und am Ende sich ja die also
das ist wichtig zu wissen bei dem Buch
gibt ganz viele Songs die eine wichtige
Rolle spielen ist aber nicht so dass die
Songs zu dem Buch geschrieben wurden
sondern das Buch ist zu den Song
geschrieben worden es gab natürlich
schon einen ein Konstrukt aber nicht ist
dann quasi an die Songs angepasst worden
das kann ich eigentlich wirklich mega
spannend und das lustige ist tatsächlich
dass den Song nicht eigentlich dafür
geschrieben habe
der da nicht da drauf gelandet ist
und bei mir dann einfach auch so ein
bisschen dass er wurde nicht rechtzeitig
fertig tatsächlich und dann hatte ich
aber ein paar Monate vorgeschrieben aber
der passt genau da drauf und dann haben
wir den jetzt vorgeschlagen und dann war
das auch so empfunden dass der genau
passt super geil und einfach wirklich
ganz guter Typ das ist eigentlich mir
das Wichtigste ich arbeite sehr gerne
nur Menschen die ich auch wirklich wo
das wirklich eine Zusammenarbeit ist und
man sich auch mag und auch mal ein
Bierchen miteinander trinken gehen würde
und das war da sehr stark gegeben guter
Typ freue mich auch schon wenn ich mal
mit ihm drehen darf
vielleicht so eine Halloween Torte
irgendwas gruseliges was machst
irgendwas ganz schlimmes
also guck mal der ist jetzt noch weich
ne das siehst du den lassen wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen stocken also bisschen
fest werden und sobald er fest ist
drehen wir ihn machen wir gleich
zusammen würde ich sagen wie lange
dauert das nächste Spiel schaffen wir
das also schaffen wir jetzt kommt Spiel
Nummer 1 okay bin ganz aufgeregt
so herzlich willkommen bei zu Gast bei
Sally herzlich
wir werden heute ein tolles Spiel
spielen und zwar what's in the box
ihr dürft nicht reinschauen ganz wichtig
ihr habt 30 Sekunden Zeit wäre natürlich
schneller antwortet der Punkt und die
Hand darf nicht rausgezogen werden ganz
wichtig und langsam reingehen wir wissen
ja nicht was da drin ist deswegen ganz
langsam und vorsichtig reingehen ja wie
immer im Leben
oder
kurze Frage was leben das ist nicht drin
nichts ekliges und nichts Gefährliches
wir sind ja nicht bei Dschungelcamp ich
bin ich bin bereit mental nicht aber
körperlicher für die erste Runde ihr
dürft gerne einmal kurz ins Bad gehen
eure Hände waschen und zurückkommen
Hände waschen aber hier steckt nicht
meine Katze rein
wir beginnen jetzt mit dem ersten Spiel
gut Toilette
so ihr dürft
Auftritt der Gladiatoren
ich kann nichts dafür eine Hand darf
jetzt rein Augen zu wie Augen zu
schließen
ach so
das ist ein Tier das ist ein Hund oder
eine Katze oder Pferd
eine Antwort
[Gelächter]
gut
darf ich fragen wie lange das Spiel geht
wie viel runden dass mich mental drauf
einstellen
1 2 3 Goa
[Gelächter]
schlagsbar
nein
ich gebe euch einen kleinen Tipp es ist
was für Männer Rasierschaum
[Musik]
1 2 3 go
was ist eine Perücke
[Musik]
ich finde das eklig ist es bald vorbei
so okay
wir hatten Einhorn wir hatten
Rasierschaum wir hatten Haare bekommen
drei zwei eins go
Marshmallows
brauche
ist das noch einzuholen überhaupt dieser
unglaubliche Vorsprung
so
ein bisschen feucht wird
drei zwei eins los
das ist so warte warte warte warte warte
warte warte das ist eine Orange
deswegen das war das verräterische da
ist man auch ganz gerne noch mal am
Gramm
[Gelächter]
so jetzt meine Runde es gibt einfach
ganz schnell rein
mal gespannt ihr dürft ihr habt nichts
drin was weh tut mir jetzt schnell
reingehen nein
Gummibären nein
gehen
[Gelächter]
wie heißt denn das so ein haarwickelteil
du weißt wie man sowas nennt
mich
keine Ahnung
[Gelächter]
warum
okay
letzte Runde ja
danach noch als ach so das falls ich
falls es zum Stechen kommt ja natürlich
Vorsichtigkeit und drei zwei eins du
deine Hände also ich nicht
habe ich auch eben nicht 3 2 1 los
[Gelächter]
in der Nase vorne
das wäre fast eine Arbeitsunfall gewesen
mich
[Musik]
oh Gott ich habe den Mann versprindt
gemacht was denn Trommelfell zerstört oh
mein Gott
also ich will ja wirklich nicht sagen
aber das war das schlimmste
[Gelächter]
sauber ich würde sagen ihr müsst wieder
in die Küche ne
wir sehen uns später noch mal ich habe
zum Glück nicht schweineo gesagt
und dann ist mir auch gefallen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
passiert man einfach nicht
mehr raussetzen hier sieht doch richtig
gut und Schlafi aus
und jetzt ordentlich Butter ja richtig
ordentlich bist du so Team viel Butter
bei Kaiserschmarrn ja
viel auf jeden Fall gut und Zucker
machen wir dann gleich noch dazu das ist
auch die Zuckermenge
reinkippen können
oh mein Gott ich bin noch so vom Spiel
so aufgewühlt
oh Gott okay warte ich wollte dich
vorher noch was fragen echt coole Fragen
gestellt ähm ich bin ganz gespannt ja
was nämlich dein Lieblingssong von dir
ist und dein Lieblingssong von anderen
Künstlern und was du hörst also er hörst
du so deutsch englisch
also mein lieblingsson von mir ist
wirklich immer eigentlich der letzte die
ich geschrieben habe das ist einfach so
weil während des Schreibens hat mir ja
nur die Motivation den weiter zu
schreiben wenn man denkt das ist das
Beste was man hier gemacht hat das
ändert sich dann manchmal noch mal so
ein bisschen wenn wir dann so Proben mit
der Band deshalb ist es jetzt eigentlich
zu viel gewesen vom neuen Album ist
jetzt aber Magneten weil wir den bei der
Probe so ein paar Sachen da gemacht
haben die ich so geil fand okay deshalb
Magneten ist gerade Lieblingssong zweite
Frage gemacht ich habe keinen so
Lieblingsrezept immer das was ich gerade
mache also jetzt Kaiserschmarrn
dann hast du gesagt also Lieblingssong
also bester Song immer noch finde ich
also bester Popsong aller Zeiten ist
Mirrors von Justin Timberlake
finde ich eine eine eine geile Hymne
einfach unglaublich
und sonst ich höre tatsächlich wenn ich
gerade ein Album schreibe oder
geschrieben habe muss ich keine Musik
und wenn ich was höre dann tatsächlich
jetzt eher so englischsprachige Sachen
früher nur Deutsch aber wir können ja
mal über die fluffins deines
Kaiserschmarrn sprechen
und hier sehr schwierig werden
weißt du das sind so Gerichte da
da da bin ich berührt einfach weil es
einfach so schön ist optisch so schön
ist ja und weißt du
einfach schön ist
das schön
alles gut
ein bisschen anbraten und ich wir
bereiten einfach nebenher das müssen wir
euch nicht zeigen noch ein herzhaft und
so ja also sogar und da kann man
eigentlich alles an Gemüse mit
reinpacken Zwiebeln Champignons Spinat
Schnittlauch egal was einfach anbraten
durchführen und dann probieren
ich weiß wir könnten unterschiedlicher
nicht sein bis
zum in unserem Leben da haben wir hin
den herzhaften Kaiserschmarrn Spinat
Champignons das noch Parmesan drüber
Kürbiskerne richtig lecker rote Zwiebeln
und Schnittlauch was möchtest du zuerst
probieren das und dann
nehmen wir den kleinen
sind die kleinen Teller
fühlt sich auch nicht so unvernünftig an
also sehr lecker
unser Süßer kaiserschmarscht
und also haben wir sehr gut gemacht sehr
sehr gut gemacht
da sind wir beim Thema Hängebauch junge
Junge diese Eischnee
einmal durchrüttelt also wirklich sehr
lecker muss ich uns loben
vielleicht
wenn man Fleisch und Restaurant eröffnen
gemeinsam das Thema Sallys und dann
gibt's da Kaiserschmarrn
und dann kannst du herzhafte und süße
Kaiserschmarrn mit allem Toppings warum
kam nur noch kein Auto
ganz Deutschland ich bin dabei
am Abend deine Karaoke-Party jetzt sagen
wir nehmen unsere Teller essen noch in
Ruhe auf und das Team baut Spiel Nummer
so kommen wir nun zum nächsten Spiel wir
spielen tell the lyrics
ich erkläre euch kurz die Regeln ich
lese euch monoton den Text vor es ist
ein englisches Lied und ich lese es euch
auf Deutsch vor den Song er wurde von
Google übersetzt
ja so wie kann ich dazu sagen
direkt anfangen und singen aber er kann
der Ursprung war etwas anderes weil
Google ist falsch verstehen
los geht's
so der erste Song ich arbeite die ganze
Nacht ich arbeite den ganzen Tag um die
Rechnung
das habe ich noch nie gehört
ich dachte das war work work work von
Rihanna
aber so schnell
money money money das kennst doch
ich dachte wir sollten hallo wir sind
eure wetterfäden aha und wir haben
Neuigkeiten für Sie was du hörst besser
zu macht euch bereit all die einsam
Mädchen und lass dir die Regenschirme zu
Hause in Ordnung die Luftfeuchtigkeit
steigt
das Barometer wird niedrig wie niedrig
Mädchen
denken
jetzt ist die Straße der richtige Ort
wie bei allen uns besser denn heute
Abend zum ersten Mal zum ersten mal kurz
nach 9:30 Uhr zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte es wird Männer regnen Männer
regnen
Halleluja
it's Training
Rihanna
und deswegen war ich so kurz warte ich
muss überlegen wie geht Rihanna los aber
ich habe es nur am es wird Männer regnen
sehr gut hat jetzt ein bisschen näher
gedauert aber der Punkt geht an Sally
hallo ich bin es ich habe mich hallo
von äh hello
[Musik]
eine Textsicherheit bei dir die ist
wirklich irritierend
und Robbie Williams Angels
der einzige der einzige englische
Musik eine 1 mündlich bekommen heute
habe ich keine Lust irgendwas zu tun ich
will nur in meinem Bett liegen ich habe
keine Lust mein Telefon abzunehmen
hinterlassen Sie also eine Nachricht am
Ton denn heute schwöre ich dass ich
nichts tue ich werde meine Füße hoch
[Applaus]
ich habe die ganze Zeit überlegt
einen Wunsch in den Brunnen fragt mich
nicht ich verrate es nie ich schaute zu
dir während es viel und jetzt bist du in
meinem Weg ich tausche meine Seele für
meinen Hund
für einen Kuss das habe ich nicht
gesucht aber jetzt bist du mir den Weg
dein Blick nicht ab zerrissene Jeans
Haut zeige ich zeige sich heute Nacht
Wind weh wo willst du hin Baby
hey ich habe dich gerade getroffen und
das ist verrückt aber hier ist meine
Nummer also ruf mich vielleicht an es
ist schwer
[Musik]
auf Englisch übersetzt
wie Butter wie ein undercover
so kommen wir zum nächsten Song ich
sitze und warte betrachte einen Engel
mein Schicksal und wissen sie ist die
Orte an die wir gehen
[Musik]
gesagt habe Angels sleepings
sehr gut
geglaubt tolle abzusagen aber
Katastrophe okay wir haben jetzt einen
Song für euch einen deutschen Song
breat night under
sie was Max Giesinger mit uns macht Atem
los Schwindel
habe ich mir selber ein Foto bringen
[Musik]
totale sexlied ist das ist gar nicht
jugendfrei da geht's entschuldige bitte
denk doch mal drüber nach
das ist so der Schlager der Schlager
Hörer der hört sich den Text nicht an
das ist total das obszöne Lied
[Musik]
angeht oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott atemlos durch die Nacht was
soll das bedeuten das ist ja nicht oh
wir sind wir machen gerade Stepptanz
irgendwo sondern es ist eher wir machen
tanzen in einem Raum
durchgehen
ist natürlich eine Interpretation ja
also wow ich glaube das wussten
Fifty Shades of grey das könnte da
können wir treffen uns alle also
in die Kommentare Wahnsinn ist auch
lange nicht groß irgendwie letztes mal
sagen hören und dachte das ist sehr gut
so
ja das letzte Spiel wird natürlich wie
bei uns traditionell ist in unserem Shop
finden okay
super dann bis gleich cool
da sind wir wieder wir sind doch nicht
im Shop
tim hat mir erzählt oder gezeigt dass er
gerne malt dann kam uns die Idee komm
lass gemeinsam mal aber mit der
Challenge du hast ja gesagt du malst
nicht mit Pinseln sondern eher mit ähm
also der spachtler
und heilige Nacht wenn wir die Garage
voll mit Farben Leinwänden die Küche ist
voll mit Backzubehör lassen uns was
malen ein Kunstwerk erschaffen mit
Küchenzubehör back und Kochzubehör oder
wir Farben wir können uns keine Ahnung
sollen wir uns ein Thema überlegen
Farbkonzept frei Schnauze also ich würde
vorschlagen ich bin der Kleber ich
bekleben mich auch gerne und du suchst
Farben aus okay ich gebe dir mal was ab
und du kannst sie dann überlegen welche
Farbe dann kommen und dann gucken wir
wie wir da mit den Sachen irgendwie eine
Strukturen kriegen ich glaube die Farbe
ist durch ich würde sie jetzt auch
Pass auftragen
was machst du da eine andere Farbe rein
oh Stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp
was wolltest du eigentlich mit der Rolle
normalerweise
ist aber auch gut so massieren
will ich das im Detail wissen oder
lieber nicht nee das war hier in der
Küche
boah das ist aber hier wirklich hast du
eine sehr gute Farbe hier
angemischt
sehr gut
ich krieg
[Musik]
nicht genug
okay aber es ist natürlich ein Wortspiel
mit Art Kunst
geil so das ist echt ein meine schönste
Unterschrift jemals gemacht habe
also das wird dann versteigert ja
Spenden einfach an guten Zweck finde ich
richtig gut oder machen wir perfekt das
Bild trocknet hier und jetzt fahren wir
das heißt euch alle herzlich willkommen
hier in unserem Shop in Mannheim einmal
Krisen Applaus für beides Sally und Tim
Bendzko bitte nicht
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen danke
ich habe ihnen gewinnen lassen
nein er hat er ist bisher fair in
Führung ja jetzt wollen wir das letzte
Spiel hier noch machen und ist schön
dass Ihr alle mit dabei seid
so und dann kommen wir zu unserem
letzten finalen Spiel wir spielen gibt
es Sounds das bedeutet
ihr erratet einen Song
anhand von den ersten zwei Sekunden
beziehungsweise 1 bis 2 Sekunden ich
kann doch keine Lieder erraten wie oft
denn noch
der Musiker ich nicht
singst du sie vor oder spielst du sofort
okay seid ihr bereit bei falsche Antwort
auf der anderen natürlich noch antworten
das ist wichtig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Lady Gaga und Bradley Cooper mit
shallows shallow heißt der Song richtig
ein Punkt
[Applaus]
auch ein blindes ist jetzt ein bisschen
älter das Lied mal schauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ich glaube
everybody
so langsam
[Applaus]
du Streber
Matthias Schweighöfer hoch
fast ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist doch Heidi richtig
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
du musst über die Choreo in den Sonnen
kommen
[Musik]
was ich gesungen habe
[Gelächter]
von Michael Jackson
tut mir leid war nicht absichtlich
[Applaus]
das war leider schon der letzte Song
der Altersvorsprung ja das ist wie man
auf die 40 zugeht dann
das war leider schon der letzte Song
jetzt einmal die Punkte zusammen ich
glaube es ist eindeutig nein Punkte für
und 16 Punkte
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
geil da kommt jetzt zu deinen ganzen
anderen Awards neben die Goldene Kamera
super toller Gast Dankeschön
Dankeschön viel Spaß ich freue mich sehr
auf das Konzert in Köln freue mich auch
sehr aufs neue Album ich hoffe ihr hört
alle rein april kommt immer april nicht
am ersten April aber ein Tag davor
ganz genau also hört gerne rein
unterstützt unsere Künstler hier in
Deutschland finde ich ganz wichtig denn
ähm ihr seid toll du bist toll danke
schön vielen Dank gibt's noch Konzert
kann oder schon alles
vorbei
wird bestimmt ein ganz ganz tolles Album
singen
auch das ist wirklich also macht's gut
tschüss
[Applaus]
zu viel Luft im Kreis bewegt so viel
dass ich nicht mehr versteht so viel zu
viel doch ich krieg nicht genug
also Wintertag sind auch wieder eng in
der Sache
einfach direkt mit und der LKW kommt
hinterher so habe ich mir das auch
gedacht ja vielen vielen Dank freue mich
sehr
viel Spaß was mache ich damit
zum Reinigen von
rein und die Hitze
für den Zuckerhaushalt richtig ja vielen
Dank ich freue mich wirklich sehr schön
vielen Dank fürs Einschalten schreibt
uns das Video gefallen hat ja Tschüss
wir sehen uns in Köln
auf dem Kreis bewegt so viel dass ich
nicht mehr verstehe zu viel zu viel doch
ich krieg nicht genug ich krieg einfach
nicht genug
ich krieg nicht genug